ya hemos aprendido bastante acerca de
resistor es en serie y en paralelo ya
aprendimos cómo simplificar resistor es
en serie o en paralelo a un solo
resistor equivalente ahora solo como
repaso vamos a escribir por aquí que el
resistor equivalente en serie es igual a
la suma de los resistor es en serie r
uno más r 2 y si tenemos resistor es en
paralelo y eso significa que comparten
los nodos podemos encontrar la
resistencia equivalente en paralelo r
paralelo y si son dos los resistor es
que están en paralelo la fórmula nos
dice que r paralelo es igual a r uno por
r 2 entre r uno más r 2 pero si tenemos
más de dos resistor es en paralelo por
ejemplo si tenemos tres receptores en
paralelo la fórmula del resistor
equivalente en paralelo nos dice que uno
entre r paralelo es igual a uno entre r
uno
1 / r 2 + 1 / r 3 ahora si tuviéramos
más resistor es en paralelo aquí
simplemente tenemos que sumar los
términos adecuados y es una fórmula que
sirve para cualquier cantidad de
resistor es en paralelo y estas dos
fórmulas hacen exactamente lo mismo
aunque es más conveniente utilizar estas
y tenemos únicamente dos resistor es
pero bueno aquí en este problema de este
vídeo tenemos un circuito de resistir es
bastante complicado tenemos todos estos
resistor es y la pregunta que nos vamos
a hacer en este vídeo
si tenemos aquí esta fuente de voltaje y
la conectamos al circuito aquí tenemos
los dos puntos de conexión si conectamos
esta fuente de voltaje qué tipo de
corriente vamos a obtener ok esto es lo
que yo quiero conocer y si lo vemos
fijamente nos preguntamos oye y cómo
vamos a resolver este problema lo
importante en esta parte aquí es
detenerse un minuto y simplemente
observar cómo se ve el circuito deja que
tus ojos recorran el circuito como
quieran y encuentra patrones que puedas
reconocer así es que simplemente detente
ahí y obsérvalo por aquí este estará en
serie con algún resistor definitivamente
no
pero estos dos si están en paralelo y
éste no la verdad no veo un patrón de
entrada y salida pero estos dos resistor
es si están en serie y los podemos
simplificar así es que tenemos algunas
posibilidades para simplificar este
circuito y una de las preguntas
oye pero por dónde empiezo y una forma
de hacerlo es irnos lo más alejado
posible de lo que nos interesa calcular
y lo que nos interesa calcular es esta
corriente de aquí así es que una buena
forma de empezar este problema es irnos
hasta el final del circuito y luego hiló
simplificando en esta dirección y bueno
aquí estamos yendo en el orden contrario
a como leemos algunas oraciones pero
cuando estamos hablando de los circuitos
eso no importa así es que lo que voy a
hacer es empezar por aquí en este lado y
vamos a desensamblar este circuito e
irlo simplificando paso por paso ahora
en estos momentos nosotros ya hicimos
todo el trabajo pesado ya tenemos aquí
nuestras fórmulas y únicamente
necesitamos aplicarlas ya sabemos cuál
es nuestra incógnita sabemos por dónde
vamos a empezar así es que debe de ser
un proceso muy sencillo bueno ahora sí
vamos a empezar a simplificar este
circuito vamos a empezar por aquí
tenemos dos resistor es en serie como
están en serie usamos esta fórmula y
tenemos dos oms más 8 oms eso es igual a
10 oms así es que puedo borrar estos 2
resistor es y reemplazarlos con un
resistor de 10 oms ok
este es el registro equivalente de 10
oms y este fue el paso número 1 y ahora
lo que tenemos que hacer es volver a ver
el circuito vamos a empezar por aquí y
lo que tenemos son 2 resistor es en
paralelo entonces ahora vamos a usar
esta fórmula de aquí tenemos 2 resistor
es en paralelo así es que vamos a usar
esta versión de la fórmula de resistor
es en paralelo porque es más fácil de
utilizar rápidamente y la fórmula nos
dice que tenemos que poner 10 por 10
entre 10 + 10 esto de aquí es 100 y esto
de acá es 20 o sea que esto son 5 oms
ahora aquí pudimos haberlo hecho mucho
más rápido porque estos dos receptores
en paralelo tienen exactamente la misma
resistencia y entonces sabemos
directamente que su resistencia
equivalente es la resistencia entre dos
pero bueno aquí lo que tenemos que hacer
es sustituir a estos dos receptores en
paralelo por el resistor equivalente de
5 ohms 5 oms aquí ya se puede ver
claramente hacia dónde va esto estamos
colapsando todo el circuito aquí tenemos
dos receptores en serie usamos esta
fórmula tenemos un +5 oms eso es igual a
6 oms entonces puedo reemplazar a estos
dos resistor es reemplazando resistor es
por un registro de 6 oms
y ahora que tenemos por acá bueno pues
ahora tenemos tres resistor es en
paralelo eso está un poquito más
complicado y ahora sí vamos a tener que
usar esta fórmula de aquí para resistor
es en paralelo donde tenemos más de dos
resistor es así es que tenemos que uno
entre el resistor equivalente en
paralelo es igual a uno entre la primera
resistencia doce más uno entre cuatro
más uno entre seis y aquí el denominador
común es 12 vamos a ponerlo 12 y aquí
tenemos uno más 3 por 4 12 así es que
aquí tenemos un 3 más
2 x 6 12 o sea que aquí tenemos un 2 y
esto es igual a 6 entre 12 o sea un
medio ahora esto es 1 / rp entonces
rp es igual a 2 entre 1 o sea rp es
igualdad 2 2
homs y éste resistor equivalente en
paralelo va a reemplazar a estos 3 así
es que los tenemos que borrar y
reemplazar por el registro equivalente
de 2 oms finalmente el último paso aquí
tenemos dos receptores en serie 1 2 es
igual a 3 1 + 2 es igual a 3 así es que
hemos llegado hasta el final
este es el resistor equivalente de 3
y ya terminamos ya estamos listos desde
el punto de vista de esta fuente de
voltaje está mandando suficiente
corriente como para que aquí tengamos un
resistor de tres oms todo ese circuito
complicadísimo que teníamos con
distintos resistor es esta fuente de
voltaje realmente no lo puede distinguir
de un resistor de tres oms para ella son
exactamente lo mismo
así es que tomamos un circuito bastante
complicado y lo simplificamos a uno muy
simple y estos son los pasos que uno
tiene que seguir para simplificar
cualquier circuito nos fijamos en cuál
es la incógnita que nos interesa y
después nos vamos hasta el extremo
opuesto del circuito y desde ahí vamos
simplificando paso por paso hasta que
llegamos a un circuito tan simple como
éste